a French prayer in the German city of
Berlin here in the French Cathedral the
European neighbours hold mass side by
side together they commemorate the
victims of the Paris attacks many people
turn to church council member clodine
for help even though she herself is
struggling to keep it together
especially this is D hina feel cool it's
what happened was completely arbitrary
oh there's no explanation evil cannot be
explained especially when it results in
the deaths of children and young people
know until mention there's a feeling of
deep grief and shock among the
worshippers the mixed congregation of
German and French Christians was hard
hit this so let's be us here in bed in
division it's almost as if it had
happened here in Berlin and I believe
that the politicians and everyone in
Germany feels this way wooden scar we
feel a strong connection to Paris and
that's getting stronger a crowd
gathering on the square in front of the
French Embassy in Berlin shared the same
message solidarity with Paris despite
the rain these people came to lay
flowers and light candles many came
despite having no direct connection to
France and knowing no victims personally
you've been here I am here to express my
sympathy for the many many people in
France who have lost their lives during
the terrorist attacks I would like to
set an example and show that I am
against every type of terrorism earth
this is the second time clodine horn on
has come here to commemorate lives lost
since the attack on French magazine
Charlie Hebdo 10 months ago you sullied
ret to you guys you can see the
Solidarity here and that is very moving
10 months ago our values were under
attack vanta and now we are beginning to
realize that it's the people who are
under attack does lo to revere Dion
calculation warden
hand in hand people like these help each
other overcome their grief and trauma